letztens gab es mal wieder einen
riesigen hit storm chasers sir richard
branson und diverse andere milliardäre
sind im letzten jahr ins weltall
geflogen aber nicht um wissenschaft zu
betreiben oder ob so was in die richtung
sondern quasi nur so zum spaß so viel
co2 ausstoß nun damit ein paar
superreiche das weltall sehen können was
für eine verschwendung lautete die
kritik aber wir wären ja nicht doktor
watson wenn wir so etwas nicht
hinterfragen würden wir wollten wissen
wie viel umweltschäden verursacht so
einer rakete eigentlich wirklich easy
peasy fünf minuten video kurz und
knackig haben wir gedacht die recherche
hat uns dann aber mehrfach überrascht
co2 ist zum beispiel gar nicht das
größte umweltproblem von raketen und so
etwas hoch komplexes wie
raketentreibstoff kann man tatsächlich
aus abfall herstellen also holt euch ein
popcorn geht noch mal auf die toilette
meldet euch für die nächste woche
überall ab denn hier kommt unser fünf
minuten video darüber wie
umweltschädlich raketen eigentlich
wirklich sind
[Musik]
dass ein raketenstart mehr emissionen
verursacht als eine fahrradtour ist
wahrscheinlich ein klar wenn man diese
emissionen jedoch genau beziffern möchte
dann wird es schon schwieriger viele
wissenschaftlich belegbare zahlen gibt
es hier leider nicht und manchmal haben
wir selbst für den gleichen raketentyp
sehr unterschiedliche zahlen gefunden
viele quellen zitieren im schnitt 200
bis 300 tonnen co2 pro raketenstart
manche schätzungen gehen hoch bis 540
tonnen genau wissen tut es allerdings
niemand die fällt hinein von spacex ist
einer der drei raketentypen die 2020 am
häufigsten gestartet sind sie stößt pro
flug ungefähr 390 tonnen co2 aus das
schätzt zumindest ein umweltgutachten
der us luftfahrtbehörde
das ist der jahresverbrauch von rund 40
deutschen oder einer ganzen kleinstadt
in somalia ist das jetzt viel darauf
gehen wir später noch ausführlicher 1
klar ist dass jedes hobby natürlich
irgendwo unnötiges co2 verursacht aber
neben regenwald anzünden oder eisbären
jagel gehören weltraumflüge
wahrscheinlich unter die top ten der
umweltfreundlichsten hobbys doch
insgesamt macht der co2 ausstoß von
raketen starts nur einen ganz ganz
kleinen teil der emissionen der
luftfahrt branche aus übrigens haben wir
euch wie immer unsere komplette
recherchearbeit transparenten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt immer wenn
ihr sowas hier seht könnt ihr euch die
entsprechende quelle dazu unten in der
video beschreibung anschauen und selber
durchlesen okay ist also doch alles gar
nicht so schlimm
ab hier wird es komplex denn der
umwelteinfluss an der rakete geht ja
weit über den co2 ausstoß beim start
hinaus da gibt es erstens die mission
und vor dem start zweitens kommt die
umweltverschmutzung die durch den start
am boden entsteht dazu und drittens gibt
es auch noch den einfluss den die rakete
auf die atmosphäre und somit das klima
hat zur komplexität hinzu kommt dass
jede rakete und jeder treibstoff in all
diesen kategorien anders abschneidet
okay aber irgendwo müssen wir ja
anfangen schauen wir uns also als erstes
mal die emissionen vor dem start an
natürlich sind da die ressourcen für die
herstellung einer rakete und der aufwand
für den betrieb eines weltraum
flughafens der verbrauch schon mal mehr
als ein gewöhnlicher bahnhof hier
irgendwo in köln hier ist es aber
ziemlich schwierig an verlässliche
zahlen zu kommen die us-umweltbehörde fr
schätzt dass 2017 am kennedy space
center rund 96.000 600 tonnen co2
äquivalent verursacht wurden das sind
die jahres emissionen von ungefähr
10.500 durchschnittsdeutschen hier sind
aber die raketenstarts noch gar nicht
mit eingerechnet
und auch sonst ist nicht ganz klar was
alles mit rein zählt und was nicht das
gilt übrigens für die meisten zahlen die
wir bei unserer recherche für dieses
video hier gefunden haben vieles ist
geschätzt viele sind näherungswerte
vieles ist unter laborbedingungen
untersucht worden nicht draußen in der
echten atmosphäre und genau das problem
kritisiert übrigens auch die forscher
community selber aber auch dazu später
noch mehr kommen wir erst mal zur
zweiten kategorie die schäden die der
raketenstart in der direkten umgebung
und in erdnähe verursacht chemische
prozesse beim start können zum beispiel
sauren regen und gifte erzeugen je nach
wind und wetter wird der saure regen
dann auch weiter getragen und schädigt
böden und pflanzen in ganz anderen
regierungen ein weiterer umweltfaktor
beim start sind die unteren
raketenstufen die ja manchmal zurück auf
die erde fallen besonders wenn sie mit
einem u dmh treibstoff arbeiten denn
diese art ist extrem giftig die
vereinten nationen haben in
zusammenarbeit mit der kasachischen
regierung 2000 viermal versucht die
umweltzerstörung davon näher zu
untersuchen
sie stufen orte an denen überreste von
raketenstarts nina gegangen sind als
ökologische katastrophen zone 1 alleine
in kasachstan gibt es davon nach
jahrzehnten voller raumfahrt eine fläche
die doppelt so groß ist wie deutschland
zählt doch die dritte kategorie der
einfluss des raketenstarts auf die
atmosphäre und hiervon gibt es drei
verschiedene unter phänomene
unterkategorien quasi die auch alle
wichtig sind das erste ist die
wolkenbildung schon ein einzelner
raketenstart ist bei vielen treibstoffen
in der mesosphäre man habe sehr
trockenen atmosphärenschicht nachweisbar
grund dafür ist der ausstoß von
wasserdampf denn hier oben sorgt dieser
für wolkenbildung an den polen klar
jetzt kann man mit den achseln zucken
und sagen na und mal ehrlich wen
interessiert es ob man den polen mal hin
und wieder ein bisschen wolke ist aber
ganz so einfach ist es natürlich nicht
wolken in der mesosphäre scheinen mit
ziemlich vielen umweltfaktoren zu
wechselwirken ob das jetzt gut schlecht
oder egal ist weiß man tatsächlich noch
nicht so richtig aber die erfahrung hat
gezeigt dass man von allem was die
sensiblen pole und unsere atmosphäre
verändert lieber die finger lassen
sollte das hat man am ende noch so etwas
wie ein klimawandel oder so und der
effekt von wolken in der mesosphäre ist
also noch nicht ganz klar welche raketen
abgase aber in der atmosphäre auf jeden
fall einen negativen einfluss haben sind
stoffe und partikel wie aluminium und
ruß damit erhöhen sie den strahlungs
antrieb also wie sehr sich die netto
einstrahlung auf der erde verändert und
damals fachbegriffe nie mit anderen
fachbegriffen erklären sollte diese
netto einstrahlung wird errechnet indem
man die abstrahlung von der erde von der
einstrahlung aus dem all ab zieht also
wie der treibhausgas effekt rußpartikel
hindern wärmestrahlung daran von der
erde aus ins all zu gelangen also bleibt
sicher gefangen und es wird auf unserem
planeten wärmer kerosin als treibstoff
mit dem zb die falken ein von spacex
arbeitet schneidet in dieser kategorie
besonders schlecht ab und auch
wasserstoff der ja eigentlich gerade er
als heilsbringer im kampf gegen den
klimawandel gehandelt wird hat oben in
der atmosphäre einen enormen strahlungs
antrieb und einen schlechten einfluss
auf das klima ebenso natürlich wie das
ausgestoßene co2 diese raketen
emissionen beim staat richten also in
verschiedenen bereichen der atmosphäre
schäden an dass rund zwei drittel dieser
emission in den höheren
atmosphärenschichten freigesetzt werden
macht die sache umso gefährlicher denn
dort verbleiben die stoffe deutlich
länger als in den unteren schichten und
können die erde so länger aufheizen je
nachdem welche studien man liest halten
die forschenden diesen strahlungs
antrieb für den erst- oder zumindest
zweitgrößten einfluss den die raumfahrt
auf das klima hat also sollten wir keine
treibstoffe mit aluminium und rußbildung
mehr verwenden alles klar ysy naja für
den ruß gilt das uneingeschränkt für das
aluminium ist die geschichte aber nicht
ganz so einfach denn es ist nicht ganz
klar ob aluminium in der atmosphäre mehr
strahlung aus dem weltall oder mehr
strahlung von der erde reflektiert sie
also kühlt oder erwärmt in unserem video
hier über geo engineering sprechen wir
mehr darüber viele studien gehen davon
aus dass aluminium partikel unterm
strich kühlend wirken in dem fall wäre
das aluminium aus den raketen abgasen in
der atmosphäre gut wenn es jedoch
erhitzen wird erwärmt dass das klima
ähnlich wie die rußpartikel ok fehlt
noch der dritte zentrale einfluss den
raketenstart auf die atmosphäre haben
die ozonschicht über unseren köpfen
nimmt schaden einmal zur erinnerung die
ozonschicht schützt uns vor schädlicher
uv strahlung aus dem weltall und was uns
bei der recherche überrascht hat das ist
tatsächlich das worüber sich die
forschenden mit am meisten sorgen machen
denn schon ein einzelnes chlor atom dass
bei manchen treibstoffen entsteht kann
mehrere tausend ozon moleküle zerlegen
aber fun fact zumindest bei manchen
treibstoffen ist der schaden an der
ozonschicht geringer wenn die rakete
nacht startet denn die uv strahlung von
der sonne legt reaktionen mit dem
imitierten chlorgas an und diese
reaktionen führen über kettenreaktionen
zur zerlegung der ozon moleküle und auch
die treibstoff auswahl kann hier helfen
denn nicht alle treibstoffe schaden der
ozonschicht gleich viel aber leider gilt
auch hier ausführliche studien in den
tatsächlichen abgaswolken fehlen
[Musik]
okay der treibstoff macht also einen
großen unterschied können wir dann nicht
ab jetzt einfach dem umweltfreundlichen
davon auswählen und gut ist nun ganz so
einfach ist es leider nicht denn nicht
alle treibstoffe können alles gleich gut
grundsätzlich gibt es in drei
verschiedene sorten feste flüssige und
hybride treibstoffe mit einer vielzahl
von untergruppen jeder von denen hat
eigene vor und nachteile die so
genannten hydraulischen also
selbstzündende treibstoffe die teilweise
dmh enthalten erinnert euch das ist das
zeug aus der kasachischen steppe sind
zum beispiel extrem gut lagerbar
außerdem haben sie den vorteil dass sie
kein eigenes zinssystem brauchen aber
wie schon gesagt sie sind super giftig
für die umwelt möglicherweise deswegen
reduzieren russland und china gerade den
einsatz von tmh ein anderer treibstoff
aus der gruppe der flüssigen
treibstoffen macht die antriebs schübe
sehr genau steuerbar das ist perfekt
sobald man einmal ein bisschen von der
erde weg ist und er gehört tatsächlich
zu den umweltfreundlichsten der
treibstoffe daher als abgas
hauptsächlich wasserstoff produziert
also elo xl hat 2 forever leider nein
denn für den staat eignet sich der
treibstoff nicht so richtig er hat eine
geringe dichte und muss bei weniger als
minus 250 grad gelagert werden das heißt
man bräuchte extrem große trägerraketen
und muss zusätzlich die ganze zeit
aufpassen dass einem das zeug nicht
schon vor dem start um die ohren fliegt
okay es gibt also nicht den einen
perfekten treibstoff eine rakete
verwendet manchmal sogar verschiedene
für den gleichen flug sie werden dann
passend zur flugphase ausgesucht an
umweltfreundlichen treibstoff wird
natürlich trotzdem geforscht hoffnung
ruht derzeit zum beispiel auf methan das
soll unter anderem die riesen schwerlast
rakete starship ins all und sogar zurück
befördern und auch die esa
experimentiert mit einem solchen antrieb
aber warte mal methan ist das nicht noch
viel umweltschädlicher als co2 ja an
sich schon es ist ein viel stärkeres
treibhausgas aber es verbrennt dafür
deutlich gründlicher als kerosin so dass
man nach dem start weniger von dem zeug
in der atmosphäre hat so zumindest die
hoffnung in laborversuchen verbrennt mit
tanz und 99 5 prozent und produziert
wahrscheinlich weniger rußpartikel bei
einem tatsächlichen raketenstart sind
aber leider noch keine messwerte erhoben
worden und apropos fehlende belastbare
zahlen das gilt auch für die
biotreibstoffe die einige start-ups
derzeit entwickeln sie sollen zwischen
40 und 86 prozent weniger emissionen
verursachen als eine kerosin rakete es
klingt ja fast schon zu schön um wahr zu
sein und ja leider wissen wir auch noch
nicht ob das tatsächliche war ist fast
alle dieser treibstoffe sind bisher nur
bei tests untersucht worden das heißt
viele angaben haben wir bisher nur von
den herstellern oder von probeflügen mit
deutlich geringerer höhe und auch über
ihre sonstige umweltverträglichkeit
wissen wir noch wenig dazu kommt die
sagenhaften 86 prozent weniger
emissionen kommen auch nicht daher dass
der treibstoff so viel weniger davon
freisetzt die hersteller haben jemand
eingerechnet dass im herstellungsprozess
weniger frisches co2 gebraucht wird da
das verwendete bio propan unter anderem
aus abfällen hergestellt wird
ok und was ist mit spacex in maskat da
doch letztens wieder irgendwas
getwittert raketentreibstoffe sollen aus
dem co2 der ganz normalen luft
hergestellt werden nun wir wissen
zumindest dass man prinzipiell co2 aus
der luft holen und in dinge wie
wasserstoff und andere kraftstoffe
verwandeln kann wenn ihr dazu übrigens
mehr wissen wollt dann schaut euch gerne
mal dieses video hier von mir an wo ich
so eine anlage besucht habe aber was
genau hat ihre maske vor nun das würde
ich euch ja jetzt sehr gerne erzählen
aber leider wissen wir einfach noch
nicht viel mehr als dass er ein
forschungsprogramm startet dass das
möglich machen soll und apropos space ex
der krasse anstieg an raketenstart ist
in großen teilen auf private
raumfahrtunternehmen zurückzuführen und
klar mehr starts bedeutend mehr
belastung für die umwelt aber das soll
natürlich nicht bedeuten dass wir nicht
auch von privaten raumfahrt profitieren
könnten all diese unternehmen treiben
auch die forschung im bereich
raketentechnik voran wovon wir
irgendwann hoffentlich alle was haben
trotzdem sollten aufpassen dass unsere
raumfahrt nicht irgendwann gänzlich von
privaten unternehmen abhängig wird
kommen wir mal von einem reichen mann
mit treibstoff ambitionen zum nächsten
über den treibstoff den jeff bezos für
seinen flug verwendet hat wissen wir
etwas mehr als über ihnen max projekt
häufig für zitiert dass dieser
treibstoff nur aus sauerstoff und
wasserstoff bestand also kein co2
erzeugt hat und das stimmt auch aber wie
eben schon erwähnt auch wasserstoff
beeinflusst die atmosphäre den
strahlungs antrieb der erde trägt so
wollten bild und bei und schädigt das
motionen außerdem ist die herstellung
von wasserstoff sehr energieintensiv
keine co2 abgaswolke heißt also leider
noch lange nicht dass der staat
umweltfreundlich war aber einen punkt
muss man chef base lassen besser als das
co2 intensive und ruß reiche kerosin
oder die mega ozon schädlichen
feststoffraketen ist sein treibstoff auf
jeden fall und auch wenn wasserstoff in
den oberen atmosphärenschichten ein
starkes treibhausgas ist kommt es
wenigstens deutlich schneller wieder
runter als co2
ok fassen wir mal zusammen was wir
bisher haben es gibt verschiedene
treibstoffe in die alle unterschiedliche
stärken und schwächen haben und
unterschiedlich umweltschädlich sind die
umweltschäden gehen dabei weit über den
co2 ausstoß der rakete hinaus den
perfekten treibstoff gibt es aber noch
nicht und muss es den überhaupt geben
wie gross ist der tatsächliche einfluss
von raketenstart auf das globale klima
in 2021 gab es nämlich nur um die 140
raketenstart weltweit davon acht man bei
dieser größenordnung kann das klima das
noch verkraften auch wenn theoretisch
natürlich jedes einzelne co2 moleküle
eines zu viel ist aber der trend geht in
eine eindeutige richtung
2021 flogen so viele raketen die noch
nie ins weltall die stanze werden immer
günstiger der markt für weltraum
tourismus boomt und immer mehr
satelliten werden ins all geschossen
gleich mehrere anbieter planen zb ein
irrtum spannendes satellitennetz für
mobiles internet alleine starling
projekt von spacex will dafür um die
40.000 satelliten ins weltall schießen
zusätzlich planen raumfahrtunternehmen
wie die virgin group von servicer
branson in zukunft 400 starts jährlich
bei so vielen raketen wurde es dann
irgendwann doch problematisch für das
klima und für unsere ozonschicht also
was können wir dagegen tun
im moment gibt es fast keine regularien
wer was mit welchem treibstoff ins all
schicken darf das ist bisher nur so
wenige starts im jahr gab haben sich
weder die gesetzgeber noch die forschung
in letzter zeit wo es mit dem thema
auseinandergesetzt die meisten studien
sind aus der zeit der ersten space
shuttles erste jetzt bekommt das thema
langsam wieder mehr aufmerksamkeit wir
brauchen also international einheitliche
regeln was raketen über unseren köpfen
freisetzen dürfen und was nicht aber
damit wir solche regularien überhaupt
aufstellen können brauchen wir erst
einmal daten wir brauchen forschung
wissenschaft denn bisher gibt es für
kaum treibstoffe verlässliche zahlen wie
viel sie von was ausstoßen und was das
dann in unsere atmosphäre bewirkt kurz
wir wissen bei keiner rakete so wirklich
wie schädlich sie eigentlich ist regeln
und verlässliche zahlen sind aber nicht
alles parallel dazu brauchen wir
natürlich möglichst emissionsarm und
treibstoffe daran basteln schon viele
forschungsprojekte doch die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir in naher
zukunft emissionslos und vor allem ohne
schäden an der ozonschicht ins all
kommen ist sehr sehr gering und hier
liegt auch ein knackpunkt die
entwicklung von umweltfreundlichen
alternativen braucht zeit und bis dahin
gilt das gleiche wie für alle
klimaschädlichen aktivitäten weniger ist
mehr
also ich fasse mal alles zusammen ein
einzelner raketenstart ist schon
ziemlich umweltschädlich im vergleich
mit anderen emissionsquellen aber lange
noch nicht besorgniserregend denn so
viele gibt es davon einfach noch nicht
da haben wir ganz andere treibhausgas
quellen um die wir uns sorgen machen
müssen doch immer mehr unternehmen
planen in zukunft zahlreiche raketen ins
all zu schießen und dann wird es
irgendwann doch problematisch für unser
klima daher müssen wir jetzt
schnellstmöglich anfangen zu forschen um
umweltfreundlichere treibstoff
alternativen zu finden und regeln
festzulegen denn eigene meinung wir
sollten erforschen welchen einfluss zum
beispiel ein neuer methan antrieb auf
die umwelt hat bevor zahlreiche
unternehmen viel geld in die entwicklung
von solchen raketen antrieben stecken
doch wirklich co2 neutral wird die
raumfahrt wahrscheinlich nie werden wir
müssen uns also als gesellschaft
langfristig fragen wie viele raketen
start brauchen wir wirklich wie viel
müssen wir ins all schießen dass sich
die usa und russland wahrscheinlich
keine militärsatelliten teilen werden
ist logisch aber wie viele
internetanbieter mit erd- umspannenden
satelliten netzen brauchen wir und für
was wollen wir den co2 jahresausstoß von
40 deutschen in kauf nehmen für einen
james webb teleskop für einen satelliten
der waldbrände überwacht oder für
urlaubsreisen
zum glück ist es deutlich einfacher den
ökologischen fußabdruck eines menschen
zu berechnen als den einer rakete mit
der app klima könnt ihr das für euch
selber tun und dann genau diese menge
co2 oft hätten damit lebt ihr dann quasi
klimaneutral dafür berechnet ihr die app
einem individuellen monatlichen beitrag
quasi deine ganz persönliche co2 steuer
mit der du dann eines oder mehrere
umweltprojekte deiner wahl finanzieren
kannst von deinen beiträgen fließen 70
direkt in die projekte zehn prozent in
die entwicklung und den betrieb der app
und die verbleibenden 20 prozent
finanzieren das marketing also zum
beispiel auch dieses video hier gerade
womit wiederum mehr klima themen
behandeln im durchschnitt kostet es
weniger als zehn euro im monat seine
kompletten co2 emissionen zu oft hätten
und on top gibt es in der app auch noch
viele gute tipps und klimafreundlicher
und nachhaltiger zu leben natürlich ist
es immer besser in missionen zu
reduzieren und sie gar nicht erst zu
verursachen als sie im nachhinein zu oft
hätten aber manche emissionen lassen
sich ja gar nicht verhindern seitdem wir
das letzte mal über klima gesprochen
haben gab es einige updates zum beispiel
ist die app jetzt auch auf deutsch
verfügbar außerdem wurde ein feature
eingeführt das sich viele von euch
gewünscht haben man kann jetzt noch viel
detaillierter seine co2 fußabdruck
berechnen mit 38 zusätzlichen fragen zu
allen möglichen aspekten des lebens und
und das ist das letzte update fürs erste
es gibt jetzt einen code mit dem ihr
zusätzlich ganze zehn bäume in eurem
namen pflanzen können und dafür müsst
ihr nur den link unten in der video
beschreibung dieses videos hier
verwenden und dann dr watson bei der
registrierung in der app eingeben dort
findet ihr auch mehr infos zu den
konkreten projekten die klima
unterstützt sowie ein video von uns in
dem wir uns kritisch mit der app und mit
dem thema co2 of setting
auseinandersetzen das könnt ihr euch
gerne mal anschauen und jetzt will ich
ganz gerne von euch wissen was denkt ihr
zum thema raketen sollten wir die
raumfahrt weiter betreiben sollten wir
sie reduzieren sollte uns das alles egal
sein weil sowieso noch viel mehr co2 bei
anderen sachen gibt schreibt mir gerne
unten in die kommentare wie immer vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
patrick